depuis que les hommes existent le ciel
et le domaine du divin
on
l'histoire de l'aviation
oh
la conquête du globe
l'âge d'or
quelque part là haut au delà de
l'horizon se trouve le seuil magique des
nuages c'est par là que s'en vont nos
rêves lorsque le vent les emporte
c'est le seuil des mythes et des
mystères de la puissance et de la
liberté mais c'est aussi le seuil de la
beauté et de la joie
c'est très calme c'est comme un drap de
satin blanc qui s'étendrait à perte de
vue et on est le roi moi j'y vais seul
je traverse le nuage je regarde le monde
en bas et je me sens limon
ce désir de voler ce besoin de se
libérer des contraintes de la terre
cette envie d'avoir des ailes d'oiseaux
et de montée vers le ciel ont fait
naître l'un des rêves les plus anciens
de l'humanité
c'est une aspiration vers la liberté
vers le pouvoir vers un contrôle total
mais c'est aussi une aspiration à
quelque chose de beaucoup moins absolu
le bonheur incomparable de batifoler
dans le ciel au delà du seuil magique
des nuages
ouais le principal attrait du pilotage
vient du fait qu'on évolue dans un
espace tridimensionnel
je n'ai pas le cas quand on se trouve à
la surface de la terre en l'air on peut
aussi monter et décembre
on peut voir la face cachée des nuages
et s'amuser à tourner autour
c'est merveilleusement lui d'y évoluer
en 3 dimensions
l'époque où le rêve de voler de vin
réalité n'est pas si lointaine
elle commença en 1903 à kitty hawk
petite ville de la côte est des états
unis aient abouti au départ de charles
lindbergh pour la traversée de
l'atlantique le 21 mai 1927
après plus de vingt années d'existence
l'aviation était encore considéré par
beaucoup comme une dangereuse activités
de casse cou
c'était la sphère d'acrobates vagabond
d'aventuriers du ciel et d'ingenio
visionnaire mais lorsque charles
lindbergh relia seul et sans étape new
york à paris à bord de son spirit of
saint louis le rêve devint une promesse
et le destin du monde allait changer
charles lindbergh est une figure clé de
l'histoire de l'aviation
tout d'abord il a réalisé quelque chose
que personne n'avait fait avant lui il a
effectué la traversée de l'atlantique en
solitaire et en plus c'était un symbole
il déjeune grand mince séduisant il
portait les cheveux en bataille
il était irrésistible mais il aurait pu
être aussi le fils de vos voisins
il était le fils idéal c'est ce gars là
intrépide séduisant qui grâce à la
technique avait réussi à franchir une
nouvelle frontière
comment
la traversée en solitaire de lindbergh
prouvait la validité de certains
perfectionnement technique qu'elle et
avoir leur importance au cours des
années suivantes les moteurs avaient
acquis une plus grande fiabilité et ont
disposé de nouveaux instruments comme la
boussole à induction terrestre cette
traversée était une préfiguration de
l'avenir on ne pouvait pas encore
transporter les passagers au dessus de
l'atlantique mais on savait que le jour
ce serait possible n'était pas si
lointain
en réussissant à atteindre un point bien
déterminé lindbergh apporte à la preuve
que l'avion pouvait voler d'un endroit à
un autre de manière sûre
l'idée que l'avion pouvait être utile
aux gens commençaient à prendre corps
hennebert de randy l'aviation accessible
au grand public
il survole à tous les états de l'union
en un temps déterminé il démontra que
l'avion était un moyen de transport sûr
et ponctuelles ceci avec la traversée
historique de l'illberg
de plus en plus de pilotes et d'hommes
d'affaires pensez à utiliser les vols
qui transportait le courrier pour
transporter des passagers
cela suscite à l'intérêt de ceux qui
voyageaient et de ceux qui allaient
constituer l'industrie aéronautique
tout à fait l'intérêt pour le transport
aérien trouve à une autre dimension
heureuse
les vols de passagers existait depuis
1910 il avait commencé avec les
zeppelins pour se poursuivre avec les
avions mais la réussite financière
faisait encore défaut à la fin des
années 20 les pilotes et les industriels
de l'aviation aux états unis comprirent
que l'avion représenter un moyen de
transport valable pour le public
après lindbergh monte à sa société de
transport aérien il y en avait des
douzaines dans tout le pays
mais c'était deux petites sociétés avec
une société qui s'appelait lignes
aériennes des compagnies maritimes après
la traversée de lindbergh ses actions
monter en flèche
personne ne savait que c'était une
compagnie ferroviaire les gens à acheter
parce qu'il y avait
lignes aériennes dans le nom après la
traversée triomphante de lindbergh en
de plus en plus de voyageurs
s'aventurèrent en avion dans le ciel
à bien des égards ses premiers passagers
étaient aussi intrépide que leur pilote
c'était le début des vols de nuit
il apparaît que nous avions pour le
courrier n'était pas équipée pour les
vols de passagers
un type est venu nous voir à l'aéroport
de las vegas et nous a dit je dois
couvrir un procès à los angeles
je dois y être le plus rapidement
possible pour que je prenne l'avion on a
enlevé un capot du compartiment courrier
on a mis un coussin on l'a installé
on lui a mis des lunettes et un casque
et on la sangle et et nous sommes partis
quand il est sorti de l'avion en
arrivant il s'est approché des cockpits
et m'a dit merci beaucoup c'était mon
premier vol de nuit
je lui ai répondu de rien moi aussi
pour que l'aviation soient considérés
comme autre chose qu'une fantaisie et
que le transport de passagers devienne
une activité rentable
il fallait un avion d'une capacité plus
grande c'est avec l'apparition du
trimoteur ford en 1928 inspiré en grande
partie par l'expérience européenne
on a pu transporter 14 passagers il y
avait une seule cabine pour le pilote et
les passagers la cellule étais
métalliques
il était très stable et capable de
transporter des gens sur des distances
de 3 à 5 100 km c'était un progrès
rapidement toutes les compagnies digne
de ce nombre voulu en avoir un pour
rester dans la course
l'ère des trimoteur fut de courte durée
elle commença en 1928 avec ford puis
stimson d'entente et les gens se sentent
plus en sécurité et trois moteurs plutôt
qu'avec deux laiteries moteur s'arrête
en 1936 avec l'arrivée du décès 2 et du
décès trop
la première fois que j'ai volé c'était
sur un trimoteur ford il faisait
beaucoup de bruit il y avait encore des
sièges en cuir
en hiver il faisait froid dans la cabane
et en été c'est est très inconfortable
en hiver si on renverser quelque chose
ça je les aime il fallait faire très
attention de ne pas glisser pour la can
il est considéré par les spécialistes
comme le premier avion de ligne moderne
c'était le premier avion qu'on peut
appeler un avion de ligne
pas simplement un avion de transport
principale caractéristique était la
vitesse comme le faisait remarquer les
pilotes le tri moteur ford décollé à 140
volé à 140 et atterrissez à 140 le 247
lui voler à 250 kilomètres heure le
principal avantage c'est qu'il pouvait
traverser le pays d'une côte à l'autre
en moins d'une journée alors que le tri
moteur ford météo moins de chemin
tout à coup le voyage de new york à la
californie en une journée de vingt
possibles
ce fut un tournant
en 1927 moins de dix neuf mille
voyageurs avaient emprunté la voie des
airs en 1931 leur nombre était passé à
presque 400 milles pour les visionnaires
de l'aviation commerciale
ce n'était que le début l'idée du
directeur de la panaméricaine juan très
était de couvrir le monde
les deux océans à cause de l'absence de
bons terrains d'aviation dans la compare
des endroits l'hydravion était considéré
comme le meilleur moyen
c'était un progrès remarquable
il y avait trois hydravion martin 130
pour la chine 1 pour hawaï et un pour
les philippines il rester en service
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit remplacé par le
boeing
le formidable boeing 314 en 1939
le boeing 314 fut probablement
l'hydravion le plus remarquable est l'un
des appareils les plus romantiques
c'était le fier emblème de la
panaméricaine
boeing 3 114 long courriers et l avion
le plus luxueux aussi bien pour les
pilotes que pour les passagers
il y avait des compartiments pour les
passagers avec des couches est amovible
pour la nuit
l'un des compartiments et servait de
salle à manger avec quatre tables le
cockpit et et spacieux il y avait un
grand espace pour le co pilote et le
mécanicien et une couchette pour le
pilote
c'était des vols longue distance
il était pas rare de voler pendant 12 ou
ses heures il fallait parcourir de 1400
milles marins pour relier san francisco
à honolulu c'était limite
s'il y avait trop de vent contraire on
n'y arrivait pas mais ici le vent était
favorable on pouvait prendre quelques
passagers en plus le problème en
quittant san francisco était d'être sûrs
d'atteindre notre destination
à plusieurs reprises nous sommes arrivés
à mi chemin et nous nous sommes rendu
compte que nous n'y arriverions pas il a
fallu faire demi tour
les hydravions de la panam occupe une
place particulière dans l'épopée de
l'aviation non seulement ils ont fait
avancer le rêve d'un pas de plus vers
les nuages mais lui ont aussi permis
d'atteindre les 4 coins de la terre
les ports exotiques décrit par joseph
conrad robert stevenson somerset moga
mais herman melville
autant d'endroits qui ne pouvait être
atteint jusque là qu'après de longues
traversées maritimes étaient à portée
des hydravions
parmi tous les appareils qui ont fait
avancer le rêve
aucun n'est aussi légendaire que le dc3
ce n'est qu'avec la technologie des
modèles d'essai de douglas le dc1 le dc2
du dc3 que l'on est véritablement entré
dans l'ère du transport de passagers et
les compagnies aériennes
il est difficile de se rendre compte de
l'impact révolutionnaire qu'un avion
comme le dc3 a pu avoir
pas seulement sur le public mais surtout
les aviateurs par exemple un ingénieur
britannique renault mais est venu en
californie visiter les usines de montage
du décès 1
il a rapporté des photos de l'appareil à
ses collègues à la base aéronautique
anglais de farnborough
ils ont refusé d'y croire ils ont pensé
qu'ils avaient photographié le décor
d'une production hollywoodienne temps
l'avion constituer un bon la série des
bimoteurs de ligne de glace commença
avec le prototype d'essai ans dont un
seul exemplaire fut construit cuisinier
eu le décès d'un et enfin le dc3 qui fut
mis en service par american airlines en
1936 et devint l'avion de ligne
standards des années 30
c'était le premier apparaît rentable
pour une combine sans l'aide du
gouvernement
les compagnies aériennes perdait de
l'argent avant la sortie du dc3
cet appareil était si révolutionnaire
avec ses l aérodynamique et sa ligne
épurée que quatre ans après son premier
vol de new york à chicago pour american
airlines +2 80% de tous les passagers
aériens aux états unis voyageaient sur
des décès 3
la concurrence entre les compagnies se
fit rude
plusieurs d'entre elles engagent airs de
jeune femme pour servir le café les
plateaux repas et s'occuper du confort
des passagers
à cette époque elles étaient
sélectionnés pour leur capacité physique
elle devait non seulement servir les
passagers mais aussi charger leurs
valises nettoyez l'avion et aidé le
pilote à l'orangé dans le hangar
j'ai commencé en 1933
je venais de passer mon diplôme
d'infirmière il fallait être infirmière
pour être hôtesse de l'air je ne sais
pas pourquoi on devait penser que ça
pourrait servir en cas d'accident mais
les pilotes n'aimait pas que des femmes
envahissent le territoire
il était désagréable tout début jusqu'au
moment nous leur avons aussi servir pas
et café ils sont devenus plus gentil je
ne considérais pas ça comme un travail
c'était tellement intéressant
on savait jamais ce qui allait se passer
qui on allait rencontrer il fallait être
toujours à l'aise et ne jamais laisser
voir notre inquiétude au passage et même
si on avait aussi peur qu'elle alors que
les compagnies aériennes peuplaient le
ciel d'un nombre croissant de passagers
pendant les années 30
certains visionnaires de l'âge d'or
trouvèrent dans le ciel de nouveaux
défis vitesse résistance altitude
autonomie de 20 autant de buts à
atteindre grâce à la technologie
le lou qui devait gars conçu par jack ce
northrop en 1927 fut une nouveauté
remarquable dans le domaine de
l'aéronautique en 1921 où il est poste
un pionnier de l'aviation en compagnie
de son navigateur à rolle de gatti à
bord de leur veille à le wind e-mails
effectué le tour du monde
elmire un temps record de huit jours et
15 heures
deux ans plus tard poste rééditer son
exploit
seul et devint ainsi le premier à faire
le tour du monde en solitaire
il en profita pour améliorer son record
de presque une journée
cherchant toujours à aller plus haut et
plus loin
oui les postes s'attaqua à une autre
barrière avec son vega la barrière de
l'altitude
équipé d'un moteur à turbocompresseur le
winnie mais parvint à une altitude de
plus de 30 mille pieds et atteignaient
une vitesse au sol de 540 kilomètres
heure sans le savoir il était le premier
à voler dans les courants de la
troposphère
lindbergh avait ouvert le chemin avec
son vol historique mais d'autres rêveurs
marchait sur ses traces et tenté eux
aussi de s'aventurer vers les mystères
cachés dans le ciel deux mois après
l'atterrissage du spirit of saint louis
en france deux pilotes militaires
halleguen burger et laisse martin partir
d'oakland en californie pour le plus
long trajet au dessus des mers il
reliait re la californie à hawaï
justement
l'année même où il est post effectua le
premier tour du monde en solitaire
amelia erhart relié à le newfoundland à
l'irlande dans son vega lookheed
devenant ainsi la première aviatrice a
effectué seul la traversée de
l'atlantique
trois mois plus tard elle devenait la
première femme à traverser les états
unis
en 1935 un millionnaire excentrique
awards
pionnier de l'aviation mis au point le
h1 un élégant monoplan avec lequel il
porta le record du monde de vitesse à
563 km heure trois ans plus tard il
effectua le tour du monde à bord d'un
lookheed 14 en trois jours
9h17 la moitié du temps qu'avait mis où
il est poste les records de distance et
d'altitude se succédaient mais c'est la
vitesse qui fascinait le public pendant
l'âge d'or des quantités de course
d'avions et des spectacles aériens ont
eu lieu
même durant la grande dépression aux
états unis la national et reis à
cleveland à laquelle participaient
quelques uns des plus grands noms de
l'aviation attira des dizaines de
milliers de spectateurs payants
l'amour de la vitesse a toujours été un
élément clé de l'aviation depuis
l'époque où glenn curtiss remporta la
première coupe gordon bennett
les pilotes ont essayé de faire voler
leurs machines de plus en plus vite
c'est grâce aux récompenses que tant de
progrès ont eu lieu les progrès dans la
conception des moteurs dans l'hérault
dynamique et dans la structure des
avions ont tous été réalisés parce qu'il
y avait une course et appris à gagner
l'un des avions les plus rapides et les
plus élégants de l'âge d'or fut le djiby
weather conçu et fabriqué par les frères
grand ville de springfield dans le
massachusetts
il fut internationalement reconnue
lorsque jimmy doolittle avait battu le
record du monde de vitesse sur le modèle
r 1 avec 470 7,5 km heure emblème de son
époque le djib y était aussi réputé pour
tuer ses pilotes
certains l'ont surnommé l'appareil le
plus instable de tous les temps
jimmy de little a dit que c'était
l'appareil le plus instable qu'il ait
jamais pilotée et c'était le plus grand
pilote
à l'époque où cet appareil était
construit ils étaient deux fois plus
rapide que tous les engins militaires à
la pointe de la technologie c'était cinq
gars de la campagne sans études ils ont
mis au point l'avion le plus rapide de
l'époque et ils ont détenu le record du
monde de vitesse pendant quatre ans
il n'y avait pas de compagnie qui
sponsorisait les coureurs à cette époque
il fallait vraiment avoir envie de se
battre ils ont pu arriver parce que les
récompenses offertes étaient à ses
élèves
ils ont apparu des réussites avec le
modèle z
construite en 1930 avec lequel il génère
de l'argent pendant quelques années puis
ils ont financé la série r le modèle z
s'était décomposé en laye alors ils ont
renforcé les modèles de la série est cet
avion pouvait supporter une accélération
de 14 g à 720 km malheureusement il ne
le sortir jamais à cause de certains
problèmes et ils disparu avant de
montrer ce qu'il pouvait faire
plus de six ans après la victoire de
jimmy doolittle au trophée thompson sur
1 gbe les courses aériennes et les
spectacles de voltige continuer de
captiver les foules à travers le monde
même si les appareils d'aujourd'hui sont
à la pointe de la technologie moderne et
que leur vitesse et leur maniabilité
était impensable pour les aviateurs de
l'âge d'or le désir de faire partager
les joies du pilotage au public et
d'établir des records d'altitude et de
vitesse et la fascination exercée par
les nuages sont toujours les mêmes ce
que tous les pilotes essaie de faire
c'est communiquer avec le public c'est
tout ce que je cherche je leur commune
qui je suis en tant que pilote je me
considère avant tout comme un voltigeur
un danseur du ciel les exhibitions
aérienne hier comme aujourd'hui ont
toujours été la partie visible de
l'aviation quand on se trouve en face de
trois cent mille personnes dans un
spectacle de voltige
on sait qu'on partage quelque chose de
l'aviation avec se produire dans un
spectacle c'est l'occasion de montrer
aux gens ce que peut faire votre avion
on essaie de les faire aller plus vite
de les faire accélérer plus vite et ça
continuera jusqu'à ce qu'on aille plus
vite que notre ombre
notre véritable but c'est de susciter
l'intérêt chez les gens qui nous
regardent voler les spectateurs viennent
nous voir parce qu'ils aiment la
précision il aime le tonnerre et les
éclairs des avions les bruits l'effet
visuel
ce sont des choses qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs que dans des exhibitions
aérienne le public ressent un peu ce que
ressent le pilote il apprécie même s'il
est au sol il se rend compte et il a le
frisson
pendant que des aventuriers de l'air
comme et raretés poste aller plus loin
et que des gascous comme doolittle ou
yoox aller plus vite
certains rêveurs rendait le ciel plus
beau
au cours des années 30 concepteur et
constructeur ont créé les avions d'une
symétrie et d'une élégance étonnante
certains tel le beach soccer winning le
estime ryan le fleet et le great lakes
n'était rien d'autre que des oeuvres
d'art volante ses avions semble prouver
la relation qui existe entre la beauté
des formes et l'efficacité se sont aussi
pour certains les témoins des techniques
aéronautiques les plus avancés de
l'époque ces vieux coucous sont les
cabrioles et de neige le cockpit est
fier on a le vent dans la figure ils
sont faits pour la voltige
la plupart les avions modernes ne le
sont pas les avions modernes seront
faits pour traverser le pays
ceux là sont faits pour s'amuser ces
avions vous relie de passer quand on est
là haut dans un avion de 1229 au 1930
complètement restaurée on se sent
vraiment en 1929 on porte les mêmes
lunettes et on s'amuse
c'est comme si on remontait le temps on
se son prénom mais l'ex entrant à la fin
des années 30
le rêve érotique devint un cauchemar les
grandes machines volantes de l'âge d'or
n'était plus seule dans le ciel une
nouvelle génération d'engins étaient
apparues des engins qui allaient
entraîner de jeunes hommes des quatre
coins du monde dans des combats féroces
au dessus de l'europe et du pacifique
farinas
pour nous assurer que mein kampf friends
of the earth
c'est sûr que free bike racing tout cas
pas meuse
nous
l'aviation avait eu un rôle mineur sur
l'issue de la première guerre mondiale
mais lors de la seconde son rôle fut
capitale
non
le
lorsque les armées d'hitler envahir la
pologne la tchécoslovaquie les états
unis n'étaient pas prêts à la guerre en
1939 l'armée de l'air américaine ne
disposait même pas d'un millier
d'appareils
alors que la louche faf en comptait
quatre mille
specter je ne peux cautionner le
rapprochement
le sens narbonne toulouse face à la fois
partout un stand
bac pro
dès le début de la guerre il apparut que
la supériorité aérienne serait
déterminante pour une victoire des
alliés sur les puissances de l'axé
l'amérique entra dans la seconde guerre
mondiale avec les biplans encore en
service dans l'aviation militaire mais
la technologie faisait des progrès de
chaque côté de l'atlantique
bien que pauvre en matériel l'amérique
était riche en expériences et en idées
les courses aériennes et les vols record
de la décennie précédente avait permis
d'accumuler les techniques et les
modèles qui seraient les clés d'une
véritable aviation de combat
le moteur pratt & whitney qui avait
permis à howard yoox de battre le record
du monde de vitesse en 1935 fut
rapidement adapté sur les appareils de
combat américains et les bombardiers à
haute altitude furent équipés du moteur
à turbocompresseur qui avait permis à
oui les postes d'atteindre la
troposphère certains de ses avions
étaient munis des moteurs à pistons les
plus puissant qui ait jamais volé
aujourd'hui encore leurs noms sont
restés légendaires lightning l cat
corsair thunderbolt
parmi les pilotes on trouvait aussi bien
des acrobates chevronnés et des vétérans
des courses aériennes que de jeunes gars
qui n'avait jamais approché un avion
avant leur entraînement
venus d'un peu partout des universités
de la campagne il était là pour devenir
des combattants de l'air dans certains
des appareils les plus puissants mais
les plus difficiles à manier
on a entendu dire que pendant la guerre
après une formation ultra accéléré de
quelques heures on a mis tout de suite
des jeunes qui ne se destinait pas
spécialement l'aviation dp 40 des p 51
d'autres appareils de ce type
et on leur a demandé de les faire voler
mais quand un pilote a une bonne
expérience sur d'autres appareils
pilotés un mustang est un jeu d'enfant
ce n'est ni un spitfire ni un p 40 1
serai-je et ça vole vite et c'est
précieux
j'avais 19 ans lors de mon premier
combat eric c'était une aventure piloter
ses avions avec des dopants dessus voler
en formation
voir les autres c'est un grand moment
j'étais conscient de la gravité de ce
que nous fait chier je savais que nous
tuons des gens c'était un sentiment
étrange
j'ai toujours eu un sentiment
d'invulnérabilité je crois que tous les
pilotes ont connu ça je n'ai jamais cru
qu'il pouvait m'arriver quelque chose
lors de mon premier combat aérien
les japonais bombardé notre terrain
d'anvers je me suis retrouvé nez à nez
avec un oscar japonais c'était une
version militaire du zéro nous sommes
dirigés droit l'un sur l'autre en
mitraillant je n'ai pas céder parce que
je ne voulais pas l'avoir dans mon dos
au dernier moment avant le choc il avéré
sur la droite
mon aile gauche a touché son aile gauche
et j'ai perdu plus de la moitié de
l'aide mais mon p 40 s'est très bien
comportée il a continué à voler à peu
près de la même façon je suis resté en
l'air et je me suis retrouvé en face
d'un autre japonais qui a été abattu par
un autre avion de mon escadrille
on ne peut pas prévoir ce qu'on fera
avant d'être en situation
il s'agissait vraiment à vis de mort la
guerre peut paraître curieuse incertain
ce n'est pas une partie de plaisir
il s'agit de vie de mort beaucoup ne
sont pas revenus mon escadrille 48 % des
effectifs ne sont pas revues je ne crois
pas aux belles histoires de guerre
beaucoup de gens ne se rendent pas
compte
si on a une sensation de joie on voit
l'avion de son copain se faire descendre
ce n'est pas parce qu'il s'est fait
descendre c'est parce que ce n'est pas
vous qui étiez à sa place
lors de ma première mission nous avons
escorter des bombardiers en territoire
ennemi
j'ai compris que les chasseurs ennemis
voulaient notre faux quand on pense à la
guerre qu'il est ce défi sans leur père
des pères sont leurs fils des femmes
sans leur mari les maires sont leurs
fils et tout ça pour rien
la guerre ne résout rien mais pour
défendre son pays on est prêt à tuer
celui qui cherche à vous envahir et à
vous imposer son mode de vie
si c'était à refaire j'oublierai sa
canton de ma vie et je répondrai présent
bien longtemps après que le souvenir de
la guerre ne se perde dans le passé il y
eu une période où ces oiseaux de légende
avait pratiquement disparu des cieux
mais un groupe de rêveurs dévoués les
garder en état de voler et pour nous
permettre de partager leur part
d'histoire avec le temps qui passe ils
finissent par faire partie de l'histoire
ça fait 50 ans maintenant il n'en
restait presque plus maintenant on
commence à en voir à nouveau
on les retrouve dans le fond des océans
dans la montagne dans des granges on
s'arrange pour trouver des pièces qui
manquent l'on peut dans le monde
les petites les grandes et on essaie de
remonter un avion qui vole un flap ce
fut le nec plus ultra de la série des p
51 les pouvait monter en altitude il
avait la vitesse le confort et la
puissance de feu ils avaient été conçus
et fabriqués par des pilotes et des
ingénieurs qui se comprenait elle avait
quelques petits défauts mais pas
beaucoup
je ne connais rien de meilleur que de
rouler sur la piste avec un bus temps de
se mettre en ligne de mettre les gaz et
de s'envoler
c'est grisant de piloter un avion comme
celui-là il a la vitesse le bruit et
l'odeur et la verrie poker le merlin
fait un bruit bien distincts être aux
commandes mettre les gazs sentir la
puissance monter tout est grisant je ne
vois pas d'autres mots pour dire ça
ce sont des machines magnifique leur
bruit est magnifique et ce sont des
pièces d'histoire où trouve-t-on une
autre telle combinaison les gosses qui
viennent n'y connaissent rien mais il
adore ça parce que ces grands avec ce
fait ce truc là honnêtement si ç'avait
une femme je l'aurais épouser
certains prétendent que les rêves des
enfants sont les rêves du passé mais ce
sont aussi les rêves du futur
né avec les premiers jours de la
création le rêve d'icare nous a
entraînés depuis la terre dans le ciel à
la recherche du seuil magique des nuages
quelque part derrière l'horizon
l'homme sait depuis longtemps que c'est
le seuil de la joie et de la liberté de
la puissance et du pouvoir mais il sait
aussi que ce seuil mystérieux offre un
refuge à tous ceux qui sont à la
recherche de même
je crois que l'humanité continuera
d'explorer l'univers c'est peut-être
elliott qui l'a le mieux dit il a dit
quelque chose qu on note
nous poursuivons notre exploration sans
relâche et à la fin nous nous
retrouverons à notre point de départ
comme si nous venions pour la première
fois
e